this is Jonathan Ferguson the keeper of
firearms and artillery at the Royal
armories Museum in the UK which houses a
collection of thousands of iconic
weapons from throughout history and on
this episode Jonathan's back with a
classic Modern Warfare franchise this
time taking a look at the weapons from
Modern Warfare 3. Picatinny rails these
dimensions are all fixed so that
manufacturers can design accessories
that will always fit them you'll see the
gap between these ribs here these stop
Bridges is quite narrow model in the
game looks like the battlements of a
castle they're huge and they're really
widely spaced if you want to see more of
Jonathan's take on Call of Duty make
sure to check out our back catalog with
them all in you can find a link to the
playlist in the description of this
video and if there are any other games
guns and mechanics that you guys want to
see Jonathan break down let us know in
the comment section below right let's
take a look at the guns of Call Of Duty
Modern Warfare 3.
foreign
five seven I've shamelessly grabbed two
because of course dual wielding is a
thing in the Call of Duty games but this
is a pretty good copy of the five seven
specifically the second generation
fn57 now that is largely or the biggest
giveaway there first generation has a
sort of bowed out trigger guard we don't
have that second which is what's in MW3
it has this almost sig-like trigger
guard and then there is now a third
generation five seven just to confuse
the hell out of all of us where they've
completely remodeled the gun a bit like
cars get remodeled every sort of seven
to ten years they get a either a
facelift or a complete redesign and guns
are now following suit I think it
handles in game it's hard to say
realistic with a game like this but it
handles relatively as it ought to so
flat shooting as they say very little
visible felt recoil relatively accurate
but you know pistols are much of a
muchness when it comes to accuracy at
their effective range something I did
notice that I don't remember and a bit
surprised by is that the player
character is using this one-handed the
whole time other than for
the sort of palm style reload we've got
quite a bit of sort of tactical movement
in terms of handling with sort of over
the hand slide operation but we haven't
yet gone for I don't think this era of
motion capturing an actual trained
person too
get all their motions
right I'd kind of forgotten that this
was in the game this is the Magpul fmg9
which in its original form has never
been produced as a working firearm
intriguingly for those of us who study
sort of the culture of firearms um and
history and history thereof it did get
released as an airsoft gun so this is
one of those cases where it's a sort of
a replica of something that never quite
existed in the game it's it's difficult
with first person shooters gimmick guns
like this you can make a feature of them
or have them appear at certain point in
the campaign but they they very quickly
revert to being just whatever their
stats are if that makes sense which I
suppose it's true of the thing in real
life so something like this that the
only practical use for it might be
unobtrusive close protection so you've
got a VIP you need to protect you can't
be seen to have a submachine gun or a
carbine on you for whatever reason well
this gives you the opportunity to
somewhat conceal something that's more
capable than a pistol
[Music]
foreign
now I'm also including unusual guns so
this very rare Peruvian only assault
rifle turning up in Africa is while not
impossible pretty surprising so in case
anyone's wondering and I don't want to
first look this up I don't think I could
find out what fad stood for it is in
fact fusil automatico doble and it is
from Peru Peru is not not a country
known for its firearms designs yeah it's
a an unusual thing they must developers
must have come across it online before
anyone else it's not one where I can
pinpoint its emergence if that makes
sense and I just I can't get over those
sites the the coat hanger bit of wire
rear sight I mean I gather from the way
they're designed that they must be
backup sites and some sort of optic is
intended but it's not actually clear how
that would fit I have to I hate to
disparage the designers of this thing
but it it it's like a cursed gun without
being modified in any way
all right we'll pause right away on this
one this is the the infamous Remington
ACR The Branding or and marketing of
this rifle is the history of this rifle
generally is pretty interesting outside
of the US no one cares about that that
sort of branding and our example here is
clearly marked BFI Industries
Bushmaster firearms Industries not a
Remington Insight whereas Remington is
very much in sight on this model in the
game to the point where I had a sort of
pseudo Mandela effect moment once and
pick this up expecting to see that on
the side of the gun because it's not
there something I've actually noticed
just while handling this is the cocking
handle so in the game it points
downwards and on our gun it sticks
upwards either this is upside down or
the one on the gun is so I'm gonna go
away after this and check I'm sure the
comments will now
chime in with you've got your cocking
handle the wrong way up he falls
Picatinny rails on Mill standard 1913 is
fixed these dimensions are all fixed so
that manufacturers can design
accessories that will always fit them
and you'll see the gap between these
machined ribs here these stop ridges is
quite narrow so that you can have a
degree of precision in where you mount
your stuff model in the game looks like
the battlements of a castle they're huge
and they're really widely spaced so I'm
guessing that these guys were working
from maybe left and right profile images
maybe a video and did not actually get
Hands-On a real gun and weren't aware
that Picatinny is a standard
foreign
this is a very confusing designation
um there are other guns called pp90 this
is nothing to do with them so you
absolutely do need the M1 suffix does
have the a similar concept for the
magazine clearly to the pp19 bizon
hooking it at the front latching at the
back
helical feed giving you high capacity
with the bees on they went away
redesigned
um and came up with the bit Jazz at the
conventional magazine I'm not sure that
would be an option for for this even
more exotic gun but clearly helical
magazines are a problem we we haven't
really seen them catch on and this gun
seems to be kind of designed around the
mag just a bizarre looking gun which I'm
sure is why it was included perhaps the
most obvious weirdness is the real is
the um talking handle which protrudes
out of the front of the gun and you have
to put your finger right next to the
muzzle and just sort of pull back on the
stub of this Rod that runs back into the
gun to actually [ __ ] the thing not ideal
I think by by any one's standards
thank you
the usas 12 from deiu here is one uh we
actually have three somehow something
I've noticed right away is that and an
old theme on on this series The Gun is
actually mirrored unless this is some
variant that I'm not aware of these
m16a1 style sight adjustment disc on
this side is on the opposite side in the
game now
this receiver design is somewhat
mirrored it doesn't have an ambidextrous
magazine release but it does have
ambidextrous selector levers and the
forgings are basically the same both
sides because you can convert it to a
jet from the left so I suspect that's
thrown the designers off here and
they've lost track of which side that
adjustment wheel should go but honestly
who's going to notice not not many
people at all
also I think all of ours are the same
the rear sight is actually quite
different on the real gun so unlike what
I often say where the site aperture
shouldn't stick up above the site
protectors in this case the carrying
handle because otherwise they'll get
damaged this one does actually
when flipped up protrude as does the one
in the game but you'll see the aperture
in the game is enormous having spoken to
a couple of developers a lot of this
game but with others sure enough that's
exactly why they do it you turned it
into a ghost ring what's called a ghost
ring because it appears to disappear
when you sign through it because it's so
big and thin if that makes sense
otherwise it's I think it's pretty
faithful representation of how the thing
works maybe The Recoil is not what it
should be this this does still have a
bit of a kick to it then again the
working parts do
slow down
the the impulse of course I've managed
to grab the the one of our guns that's
fitted with a with the drum rank
magazine for almost certainly game
balance reasons the Cod gun has the
straight 10 round mag rather than the 20
round
drum
the the Rex revolver not named after a
pet dog or a dinosaur as far as I know
it's it's a rarity to say the least as a
modern day firstly revolver and secondly
break action revolver it's pretty much
out there on it almost on its own it's
kind of it's cool in that respect it's a
survival of the one of the earliest ways
of reloading a cartridge revolver going
back to the Smith Wesson number one in
the 1860s so it's kind of cool to see it
I can't speak too much to how how
faithful it is therefore except to say
that I'm as sure as I can be it has a
conventional extractor star shape there
see it in the game in the in the
cylinder there but the reload involves
just kind of limply tipping out the
empties except the empties aren't
empties they still have bullets on them
and this is that nerdy detail we've
commented on before the primers are
fired primers right from the start so
the the ammunition doesn't doesn't
remove the bullets to show that they're
fired and doesn't alter the primers to
show whether they're fired or not
they're always fine they've got the the
player character shooting one-handed why
not
um you're still better off with two
hands on a handgun of any kind really
and they have they've got the the sort
of physics of it quite quite nicely and
that it comes up and to the left because
of the way your bones are arranged
essentially if you don't have another
hand to support it it is going to come
up and left now I don't know I don't
know how how well it handles in The
Recoil Magnum revolvers are a handful
regardless but this is a fairly big
chunky gun and it's only 357 Magnum it's
not 44 or something more powerful so I
imagine it's somewhat controllable
visuals
CM 901 cult modular rifle so it has a
very unusually shaped magazine well and
the idea is to be able to reconfigure
the rifle for different cartridge types
now in a relatively simplistic first
person shooter you don't get to do that
you get the car the caliber cartridge
type that you are assigned effectively
so at the end of the day it becomes a
sort of Gucci skin for an M4 the other
thing is so what while the concept of a
modular and quick change barrel system
is still still relevant and the AR-15 is
absolutely still relevant that's
monolithic upper receiver with its quad
rail is a bit old hat these days the
trend now and I don't think it is just a
trend is to move back away from the sort
of cheese grater front end on rifles and
to have the continuous rail on the top
because that's great for putting all
sorts of different Optical sites laser
aiming systems whatever rails on the
sides and bottom become optional and so
you have a sort of slick tube with
either M lock or keyboard or some other
system and then you then fit a piece of
picatinny rail if that's an area where
you're likely to fit something so
unlimited configuration options are
great from a marketing perspective but
how the the user actually ends up using
the thing will dictate and feed back
into what's then produced Next meaning
that um I haven't checked but a cult
would need to update this design to keep
it multiple
right another Remington product which we
are clearly advised of again I don't
think the big script version of the logo
is quite so obvious on the real gun but
we don't have one to compare this was
some I believe developed for the US
Military and did succeed During trials
to to become the new long-range rifle as
we might call it in Britain law sniper
rifle of the US Army but something went
wrong I don't know the details and the
Barrett mrad was sort of reselected
ahead of it and that's what's gone into
production and is being adopted Instead
at the end of the day it's a bolt action
rifle with a scope in a first person
shooter they all behave pretty similarly
but this gives you a nice Gucci modern
take on a sort of medium power high
accuracy sniper rifle even if half the
time we're running around firing it from
the hip and using it almost like a
shotgun
foreign
the Accuracy International as50 is a
rarity both in real life and in gaming
reality as it were I'd kind of forgotten
that this was in Modern Warfare 3
because it's cool that it is being being
a British company and all that we do
have an as50 in the collection but the
sharp hide amongst you will quickly spot
that it is quite different now if you
look on Wikipedia you won't find very
much but there's not a huge amount on
this rifle on the whole internet to be
fair so if you have a look on Wikipedia
you'll see under operating system direct
gas impingement brackets citation needed
well here's your citation right here
that is the back end of an enormous gas
tube runs under the handguard from that
gas block all the way back to here where
it has an extension that is quite large
in diameter and actually has a couple of
piston rings machined into the end of it
where my finger is there and that whole
tube protrudes
into the bolt carrier and directly
impinges upon the bolt carrier so I
think I'm safe in saying that despite
the ongoing arguments about whether the
AR-15 is direct gas impingement I tend
to fall into the camp that it's not this
one actually is which is unusual to say
the least for for any firearm actually
not a common system so technically very
interesting semi-automatic 50 cows well
the barraticles rules the roost uh in
most people's minds this is a very
interesting British take
foreign
The xm-25 Punisher which is a
interesting name for the gun so this
came out well it was in development
through through the 2000s following on
from the failed objective infantry
combat weapon program the really big
selling point of this was the sensor
fusing and the and the electro Optical
sighting system which we see hints of
more so in Battlefield 4 where you could
actually Target a spot and then fire
over it to have the air burst behind
cover feature which is a real feature of
the xm25 system core does it with if you
hit fire it's a normal grade launcher if
you aim down aim through the site it Air
Bursts roughly near the enemy so it kind
of does the thinking for you you don't
have to program the gun program the
munition which is what you'd have to do
with the real gun so it also had the
complexity of having to press a sequence
of buttons to set your fusing to do that
kind of thing you're probably going to
want to be behind covering at a distance
anyway in which case do you really need
a self-loading capability and therefore
the bulk of a magazine and all of that
the answer proved to be no another kind
of gun of the moment that cropped up in
you know 2011 2013 and has then sort of
gone away again as it has in real life
thanks for watching everyone those were
the guns of Modern Warfare 3. we really
appreciate you watching both Gamespot
and us here at the Royal armories you
can always check out our own Royal
armories Channel where we do deeper
dives into some historic firearms and a
few other things as well on in the
pipeline really though we'd very much
like you to visit if you can definitely
come and check out either the Leeds
Museum some cool stuff here where I am
um the Tower of London and also we have
a museum of artillery
in any case we'll see you again next
time
[Music]
foreign